hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to five nights at the
chum bucket now we are continuing on
night 5 and apparently I was doing some
shots up hop me I have a crisis to solve
so apparently I was doing some things
wrong in the last episode in that I was
allowing mr. Krabs to come diving
through that window and ripping apart my
face cuz that's apparently not what I'm
supposed to be doing I'm not supposed to
turn the light off and then close both
doors because that's the only way that
he can kill me and I was doing some
other stupid things too but then again I
was doing a lot of stupid things so I
don't really know what I was doing wrong
so with that being said I should be able
to beat this in accordance with the same
way I was playing everything else but I
don't really know because a lot of these
things are a big mystery to me and I'm
not exactly sure hello mr. seizure ok so
anyway I mean I hope that I'm doing
everything right if I'm not doing
everything right I'm gonna be very
quickly dead and you're gonna see that
and everyone's gonna know how much I
failed so there's that hello
I see you Patrick why don't you go over
to your other door because I know you're
about to pop oh whoa hey hey hey uh I'm
CUBAN crap crap crap there's gotta be a
camera yeah there's gonna be a mr. Krabs
not a camera oh hey what a mr. Krabs how
are you doing I didn't expect oh crap oh
I'm dead oh I'm dead I'm dead I'm dead
oh I'm dead I'm gonna die I'm gonna die
I'm gonna die oh how do I die how do I
die oh my god I oh my god I
oh [ __ ] I'm gonna die my day whoa Nellie
okay we're okay then
alright cool that's great I love that
except I don't so we jumped immediately
back into the swing of things I know
it's been a few days since the last time
I played this but that's because I've
been doing other things this week has
been crazy busy I just moved to a new
place if you haven't seen my new home
tour already I haven't done one of those
since I first came to LA it was a lot of
clankers I would I do bizarre crap hi-oh
Oh dead I'm dead he's above me he's in
the ceiling
oh he's not even in the video on dead
hundred hundred hi okay I'm dead how how
dead I am isn't that crazy how dead I
mean god damn it ah yeah I forgot about
the camera yeah okay
yeah alright yeah me I'm just a little
confused little boy who's just wandering
around in a security office with
everyone's hello okay good bye with
everyone trying to kill me it's a
possibility
oh hi spongebob I'm just a little boy I
used to love your TV show until you
turned into a mass murderer although
technically I don't even know if I'm
actually in bikini bottom because I
don't know if this is actually the Chum
Bucket
I mean I don't want to say anything but
you know am atronics don't really work
underwater because of the whole
electricity thing but I don't want to
tell you how to live your life if you
want to be that you be the best
whatever the hell you are is you hi
Patrick hi who needs friends when you
can stay indoors indoors indoors or I'm
pretty sure I don't think he goes
through I think that's a load of ball
he doesn't go through the window that's
dumb they're dumb
AHA see toldja I told me I didn't tell
anyone else cuz I can't exactly talk to
you right now but I'll talk to you at
some point in the future through some
technology that we don't understand yet
known as YouTube I'm dead I'm dead I'm
dead I'm dead I'm dead oh so dead I'm
dead I'm dead I'm dead I'm dead
that is me Dennis me I'm dead I'm dead
I'm dead I'm dead
maybe if I shot how dead I am a little
more I'm dead I'm dead I'm dead I'm dead
I'm dead I'm just dead dad it dad
I'm detonated I'm generated got a radar
oh good I'm not dead okay so that's good
but uh what else do I need to worry
about besides everything
I mean besides everything of course
we're shiny oh there sandy how is going
there sandy all right this is a fun time
I'm uh I was doing god damnit
don't kill me please god damn it
tits I'm so worried about sandy I forgot
hi hi hi are you flumpty dumpty why is
there an egg here is that an e oh oh oh
cup got turn off the light okay turn off
the light
okay cool Hey assuming Oh
who is that
who's that there hmm fs4 [ __ ] off go
home and die now you is for you're not
cool and is for no no no never say never
go down here in the Chum Bucket
okay every time I turn that light off
mr. krabs takes the opportunity to come
say hi to me or stop at you I don't like
you go back to the Christie crib they
don't like you at all
look I just can't have him being all
around me mo what was that oh come on
how did he kill me Zeus OOP nope not
today squad ward no good night
oh hey how's it going here are you gonna
pop up in that door are you gonna pop
over there over there are you gonna dirt
did it all y'all say hello oh crap
well I'm boned I know I know I'm
beautiful naked here but you need to
calm down it's a little creepy let me be
me stop staring at my glorious naked
body can just back up a little bit there
mr. Krabs can you feel it mr. Krabs can
you feel it now can you feel it do you
feel some dammit god dammit again with
you why you gotta be here huh why you
gotta be here no one wants you here I'll
say no one likes you because that would
just be rude and I'd be hurting your
feelings
I'd be lashing out emotionally just
because I'm stressed and I don't want to
do that to you and put you in a bad
situation
and put me in a bad situation I want to
keep things generally level and okay
between the two of us okay okay okay
go [ __ ] yourself hello Patrick right in
time for me to hate you come on down Oh
get in the doorway now come on don't be
shy
there's plenty of room for you down in
hell I can't whoa no no no no please
please stop being Dickie Oh treating
critic ah
[ __ ] [ __ ] bags
am i okay okay I'm okay I'm okay
RA whoa I can't look at the camera but
I'm okay for what is that why is that
happening
oh no oh no oh no oh no no what is it
what's it what's it what is it what is
it what is it what is it what is it what
is it why is it all flashy do I was it
all flashy do oh why was it all flashy
do I don't I don't I don't know I don't
know I don't know why would you know
flashy do without deciding it I did that
means someone is messing with a
generator that probably come by come on
yes Bosque yes yes yes yes what are my
big winning muscles look at my winner
muscles mwah I'm such a winner feels
good I'll crap what do you mean you
can't that's not that's not how this
works you don't just get to roll in the
night 6:00 and say hope did okay there
you go
fine whatever bring it on I got this in
them shut up or say what you want to say
hello can you hear me yes I can't get in
the doors out here they're they're
bolted tight just hold out so a little
longer I'll try and think of something
hello okay not even gonna talk to me
anymore are you
well isn't that just rude of you sir
I can't believe this okay so I just got
survive another night night is sandy
gonna do show
I pretty sure sandy might have been the
one messing with a generator and when
everything went all flashy that's when
she was actually fiddling with it so I
just got to be mindful of that got to be
mindful of the cameras got to be mindful
of everything and then win this son of a
[ __ ] for the glorious country of Mother
America Russia whatever whoa whoa come
on
I looked away for a second for like a
second just died there was no one there
there was no one there there was no one
no one there was no one there is that a
ghost whoa
you are gonna sass me you were gonna
sass me don't come on come on come on
come on come on god oh thank you yes yes
yes yes what's happening what's your
none it says my victory
run it darn in the fight pesckow watch
ha ha what pal
yeah
Oh
hi
okay you mean to tell me I could have
gotten up and walked out at any time
but yeah hope yeah hi hello I can see
you through the glass
so can I yours they're stuck fast I
can't get it open
could you try from your side okay what
are you wearing you look a little
strange
oh oh hi how's it going hello everybody
I'm mark boy it's over well alright then
that's against the rules that's against
the rules it was six am i won
okay so there's a custom night and I
don't know oh hey what do they go up to
20 of course they do okay so ask Karen
Karen Karen well is Karen what Karen all
right whatever so if you guys really
really want me to play 20 20 20 20 20 20
20 mode seven twenty mode let me know in
the comments down below I don't know if
I'm able to beat it because I don't know
how tough it actually is but if it's
beatable I might just give it a try but
I'm not willing to dedicate like seven
to ten hours at it like I was the five
nights at Freddy's game but this was
really good I really didn't enjoy this
it was a lot of fun it was a good
challenge it had some good scares to it
I think it was a worthwhile experience
it's definitely a good five nights at
Freddy's game obviously not quite as
good as the original
it was weird with the 3d and all the
different cameras like there were more
cameras there but there was even less of
a reason to look at him which was really
unfortunate also the tip tip for
everyone out there keeping mr. Krabs
in the light is actually good because it
prevents a lot of other things from
happening so when you're playing try to
keep them there as long as possible
don't try to get rid of them because
he's actually helping you out so thank
you everybody so much for watching
remember if you want me to play the 20
20 20 20 20 20 20 mode let me know down
in the comments below and let me know
what you think in this game and also if
you have any other scary
Gamzee you want me to play let me know
that as well thanks again everybody and
as always I will see you in the next
video
Oh